pour ce club Istres bonjour
de la rédaction du Figaro merci d'être
avec nous Christian maccareillan bonjour
on est ravi de vous recevoir dans ce
club éditorialiste international au
point et à Radio Classique et Alex nous
avons bonjour Alex on va parler de ce
weekend sous haute tension en Russie le
chef de Wagner prigogne a fait vas-y et
le Kremlin avant de reculer Vladimir
Poutine sort-il affaibli de ces
dernières heures vous nous le direz puis
quelles conséquence de cette rébellion
apportée sur la guerre en Ukraine cette
dernière est-elle renforcée dans sa
contre-offensive le dîmeer Zen inscrit à
pointer la faiblesse évidente de la
Russie avant de parler de ce qui s'est
passé on va aller du côté de Marseille
où Emmanuel Macron entame une visite de
trois jours
[Musique]
et l'actualité dans nos régions avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale à
Marseille on retrouve au lien Aurélien
vierz bonjour Aurélien merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous vous êtes directeur de
la rédaction du journal La Provence et à
l'occasion de sa grande visite deux
trois jours qu'il débute aujourd'hui
Emmanuel Macron vous a accordé un grand
entretien
effectivement bonjour en entretien d'une
quarantaine de minutes très riche le
président vient trois jours à Marseille
avec un programme très dense et il nous
a réservé pas mal d'annonces notamment
sur la sécurité avec des moyens qui vont
être encore renforcés il faut savoir
qu'il y a 600 policiers qui sont arrivés
à Marseille depuis 2 ans avec des
officiers de police judiciaire en plus
notamment mais ce qu'on lui a dit c'est
que les règlements de comptes continuent
vous savez à Marseille on en est à 23
homicide depuis le début de l'année sur
fond de règlement de compte et le trafic
de drogue donc on lui demandez si l'état
allait encore s'investir davantage et
c'est ce qu'il a promis aux Marseillais
les dossiers sont nombreux on a aussi
des dossiers sur les transports avec un
désenclavagement des quartiers Nord qui
est en cours le siège de la Provence se
situe à l'orée des quartiers nord et on
est au milieu des travaux sur le tramway
qui va désenclaver donc ces quartiers
pauvres il y a aussi un dossier sur les
écoles il y a 24 chantiers qui sont
actuellement engagés sur 188 c'est très
long de construire ou de rénover des
écoles vous savez quels étaient dans un
état très délabré à Marseille donc les
premiers travaux d'urgence ont été
entreprises mais il y a encore beaucoup
beaucoup de chantiers en cours donc
voilà les dossiers étaient très nombreux
il y a le logement aussi où le Président
nous a annoncé qu'il allait
déclarer quelque chose à propos d'un
nouveau plan le plan quartier 2030 donc
on attend de voir et cet après-midi ils
se rendra également dans une cité au
contact des habitants qui souffrent non
seulement de la précarité mais également
de l'insécurité avec tous les règlements
de comptes qu'on a en ce moment sur fond
de trafic de drogue
dans la province il y a cette interview
qu'il y a le détail de la visite
d'Emmanuel Macron à Marseille parce que
trois jours Aurélien c'est une visite
d'important cette information inédit
pour le chef de l'État
oui je crois qu'il y a aucun président
de la République qui a passé deux fois
trois jours dans une ville française la
deuxième fois en deux ans le président
avait promis qu'il reviendrait pour voir
où les chantiers en été et c'est
l'occasion pour lui de se rendre sur
place et de constater par lui-même tout
ce qui a été fait tout ce qui reste à
faire puisque encore une fois les
chantiers sont très nombreux merci
Aurélien merci beaucoup évidemment
évidemment cette visite de trois jours
du chef de l'État elle sera à suivre sur
la Provence sur la provence.fr et à lire
ce matin cette grande interview du
d'Emmanuel Macron Marseille en très
grand c'est à la Une de votre journal
merci Aurélien d'avoir été avec nous
pour nous parler de cette visite qui
débute aujourd'hui on le disait un
format de 3 jours c'est un format alors
le chef de l'État l'avait de la fée mais
qu'un chef de l'État se déplace trois
jours dans une ville même Benoît
pailland le maire de Marseille dit c'est
un format qui est réservé au chef d'État
étranger ça ça montre la passion que
Manuel Macron pour Marseille à Marseille
c'est sa ville de coeur c'est ce qu'on
dit oui il aime beaucoup Marseille il
est grand supporteur de l'Olympique de
Marseille
et c'est une ville aussi où il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de problèmes c'est la
deuxième ville de France
démographiquement mais c'est aussi une
des villes une des grandes villes
françaises les plus pauvres il faut dire
que la population beaucoup de
Marseillais vivent avec des minimums
sociaux et c'est de ce point de vue une
singularité en France alors Marseille a
beaucoup changé il faut le dire quand
même moi je connais moi aussi c'est une
ville de coeur pour moi je suis pas
marseillais comme d'autres mais c'est
une ville de coeur pour moi et il faut
dire que
architecturalement et on le voit
d'ailleurs derrière vous avec cette
photo du Mucem la ville a quand même été
beaucoup transformée mais c'est une
ville qui est en proie à trafic de
drogue et ça tout le monde le sait qui
est absolument
démentiel et qui perturbe déstabilise
équilibre social de la ville on a vu
aussi qu'il y a encore quand même
beaucoup de bâti qui sont qui menacent
ruines
et on l'a encore constaté il y a
quelques mois avec une explosion de gaz
qui a été tout à fait impressionnante
dans le centre de Marseille c'est une
ville où il y a beaucoup d'insécurité et
c'est lié effectivement
au trafic de drogue et puis c'est une
ville où a été lancée et ça c'est assez
curieux faut voir comment ça marche ça a
été lancé ce plan pour l'école
qui consiste à donner au chef
d'établissement une autonomie dans le
recrutement du personnel et ce qui fait
grogner certains ce qui suscitent la
colère de pas mal de syndicats
enseignants parce que évidemment ça va à
l'encontre de des principes de
l'éducation nationale voilà il faut que
toutes les promesses qui ont été
conférées et dites soit tenu c'est loin
d'être le cas on peut dire que Marseille
en grand et bien ça reste à être prouvé
parce que tout ce que le président de la
République avait promis il y a quelques
années quand il était allé séjourner à
Marseille et bien de tout cela pas grand
chose à avancer tous ces chantiers sont
un peu en
rade si ce qui a progressé un petit peu
c'est l'envoi de personnel de sécurité
supplémentaire et le début des chantiers
notamment sur la rénovation des écoles
Christian macart vous connaissez bien
vous la ville de Marseille c'est
Marseille en grand c'est 5 milliards qui
ont été dégagés par l'État en 2021 même
Benoît Payan qui est le maire de
Marseille qui n'est pas du même bord que
Manuel Macron dit l'état affiche pour
Marseille un volontarisme très fort en
deux ans nous avons reçu plus d'aide que
mes prédécesseurs en plusieurs décennies
c'est ce qu'il dit dans une interview
avec France le chef de l'État on fait
beaucoup pour la ville de Marseille oui
il en fait beaucoup mais ça ne plaît pas
forcément aux élus locaux qui entendent
bien gérer une partie de cette
manne si j'ose dire ou en tout cas
mettre leurs grains de sel et donner
leur avis et ce n'est pas de ce point de
vue là extrêmement harmonieux la façon
dont ça se passe et il y a beaucoup de
quoique et de Bizzbee entre l'équipe
municipale autour de Benoît Payan et les
services de l'État
l'état reprochant à la ville de ne pas
faire assez de ne pas documenter
suffisamment l'effort à faire et de
l'autre côté la ville le reprochant à
l'état de procéder sans tenir compte des
élus locaux très souvent donc et comme
vous le disiez tout à l'heure et en plus
un énorme
échelon politique et qui compte c'est
Benoît Payan est issu des rangs du Parti
socialiste il a été élu de façon certes
tout à fait légale mais au terme quand
même d'un tour de passe-passe dont on a
le droit n'est-ce pas de discuter parce
que
[Musique]
lui a cédé sa place très rapidement
puisque le maire était l'élu du conseil
municipal donc il y a rien à dire sur
le plan de la stricte morale politique
et du respect du aux citoyens
marseillais je pense que il y a beaucoup
pas dire bon je m'en tiendrai là le fait
que Manuel Macron est pour première
étape l'Hôtel de Ville justement c'est
la première étape de ces trois jours
est-ce que c'est un signe en verbe non
payant oui c'est un signe mais il faut
bien comprendre qu'à Marseille le local
aura toujours la primeur même si vous
n'êtes pas du même bord on préfère à
quelqu'un qui est du bord opposé mais
qui est vraiment natif de Marseille à
quelqu'un qui vient avec des solutions
étatiques et toute la pompe est parfois
il faut bien le dire la prétention de
l'appareil étatique on préfère à
quelqu'un de local et d'élus et d'ancrer
à quelqu'un qui arrive avec l'Imperium
de la République c'est quelque chose
encore du boulot malgré ces trois jours
il a à se faire adopter mais par la
ville et d'une façon générale c'est son
problème d'ailleurs être aimé donc parce
que être compétent à lui est reconnu
être dynamique salué tout à fait accordé
être aimé et avoir cette empathie avec
le peuple de Marseille c'est une autre
affaire vous savez ce qu'on lui prête à
Emmanuel Macron parce que évidemment il
ne pourra pas se représenter en 2027 on
lui prête la l'ambition d'un jour de
venir maire de Marseille
non mais c'est vrai que c'est c'est
compliqué il faut dire aussi
il faut dire une chose aussi bah c'est
un peu ce que tapis avait aussi
ambitionné qui n'était pas marseillais
ce qu'il faut dire aussi c'est que
je suis d'accord avec Christian c'est
assez difficile de faire du National
dans une ville qui revendique sa
spécificité qui
ça mérite yonnalité si vous me permettez
ce néologisme et avec un personnage
politique qui est aussi très compliqué
parce que vous avez une droite qui a été
affaibli qui essaie de remonter un peu
la pente avec Renault Muselier qui fait
partie de la majorité présidentielle
d'ailleurs qui sera probablement un
acteur important de la municipale de
2026 et puis une municipalité qui
précédait celle de Benoît Payan qui
certes à changer un peu la ville sur le
plan architectural mais qui a été accusé
de d'être assez immobile quand même
c'est celle de Jean-Claude Gaudin
qui à Marseille un point d'ancrage dans
la circonscription alors pour le coup
sur la carte de la ville elle est la
plus centrale dans la circonscription ou
Mélenchon
est élu il a passé le flambeau à
Monsieur Bompard donc c'est aussi pour
Emmanuel Macron une sorte de laboratoire
de de l'anti extrême gauche donc
Marseille et exemplaire sur le plan
macronien politique général exemplaire
de ce que Macron voudrait faire bouger
et on suivra cette visite pendant ces
trois jours on va parler de ce qui s'est
passé ce week-end en Russie avant de
vous entendre messieurs on va voir les
temps forts de ces dernières heures avec
Adrien
un bain de sang éviter mais un week-end
sous très haute tension en Russie ça me
dit des troupes et des véhicules blindés
de Wagner entre dans la ville de Rostov
sur le don dans le sud du pays le groupe
paramilitaire russe prend le contrôle de
site militaire et le chef de Wagner
promet de libérer le peuple russe il
accuse le ministre de la Défense et le
chef d'état-major russe de sacrifier des
milliers d'hommes en Ukraine nous avons
réaffirmé beaucoup de nouvelles choses
un très grand nombre de territoires ont
été perdus des soldats ont été tués 3 ou
4 fois plus que ce qui est indiqué dans
les documents présentés aux dirigeants
efghani Prigogine a moins de 400 km de
Moscou Vladimir Poutine demande à la
Russie de s'unir face à un risque de
guerre civile c'est un coup de poignard
dans le dos de notre pays et de notre
peuple
une trahison provoquée par les ambitions
démesurées et les intérêts personnels du
chef de Wagner samedi soir coup de
théâtre le chef de Wagner avorte
finalement la rébellion en cours les
combattants quitte le QG militaire dont
il s'était préparer à Rostov puis
s'éloigne des régions au sud de Moscou
c'est maintenant le moment où le sang
peut couler nous faisons reculer nos
colonnes et retournons dans les camps de
campagne dans la région de Moscou le
régime d'opérations antiterroriste
restant vigueur d'importantes
patrouilles de police sont toujours
déployés à l'entrée de la capitale un
épisode révélateur d'importantes
dissension en Russie d'après Anthony
winten cela défi directement l'autorité
de Poutine donc cela soulève de vraies
questions et révèle des fissures réelles
la Maison Blanche et le Pentagone a été
déjà informé du plan d'aiguillé
prigognes le Kremlin a promis que le
patron de Wagner échapperait à toute
poursuite judiciaire et pourrait
rejoindre la Biélorussie sa localisation
est inconnue pour le moment
Christian macaron quelle leçon il faut
tirer de ce qui s'est passé ces
dernières heures de cette rébellion
avortée de la part de prix gaugine et de
Wagner la première leçon à tirer c'est
que ce que Poutine a installé comme
système de pouvoir lui saute à la figure
et que il a au fond si on se place de
son point de vue ce qu'a Dieu ne plaise
mais enfin on a le droit de faire des
suppositions ou des hypothèses de son
point de vue il aurait même dû liquider
et brigogine bien plus tôt la preuve est
faite que Prigogine avait pris
énormément de poids
ne l'a pas fait plus tôt c'est parce
qu'il ne le pouvait pas
ou qui ne le souhaitait pas parce que
Prigogine rendait des services notamment
le siège de barmut a été médiatisé de
façon mondiale grâce à la présence de
pluie gauche et c'est plus rigides qui a
donné cette importance là à la prise de
marmotte
construit simplement voilà quand on
invente des milices pour subvertir des
États étrangers exemple
l'expulsion de la France en Afrique
c'était un début de Wagner quand on
invente des systèmes aussi diaboliques
il faut être sûr de pouvoir les
contrôler jusqu'au bout parce qu'en
étant spécialiste de la subversion des
États étrangers monsieur Prigogine est
devenu aussi spécialiste de la
subversion à l'intérieur de la Russie et
c'est ce qui s'est produit la façon dont
il a occupé la base de Rostov sur le don
enfin je crois qu'on se met en mesure
absolument pas
l'importance que ça a pris rust of sur
le nom c'est la base à partir de
laquelle toute la guerre de la Russie
contre l'Ukraine est dirigée or voilà
que cet homme avec paraît-il 25000
hommes c'est lui qui le dit c'est assez
peu crédible sans doute moins que cela
mais donc avec peu d'hommes prend la
base opérationnelle de toute la guerre
sans combat donc il y a une espèce de
mollet ou en tout cas d'acceptation
peut-être parce que
étant très populiste il a réussi à
convaincre la base de l'armée que les
officiers étaient incompétents et
corrompu mais peut-être aussi parce que
tout simplement il y a une lassitude et
c'est ça que montre la folle aventure de
Prigogine c'est que la Russie est
fatiguée globalement tout le système
poutinien et fatigué par cette guerre la
preuve c'est que l'État russe et le FSB
est il est si le Vicky tous les services
ce qu'on appelle les structures de force
non pas réussi à maîtriser la situation
et ça leur a explosé au visage c'est la
preuve tout de même que le système est
concurrencé donc aujourd'hui de mon
point de vue un délitement a commencé
fortement et je pense qu'il va se
poursuivre ouais on va en parler mais
d'abord un mot pour bien comprendre avec
vous Alex sur qui est il y avait gagné
prix gaugine le chef de Wagner alors
jusqu'à cet épisode c'était un proche de
Vladimir Poutine yefghani Prigogine à 62
ans il est natif de Saint-Pétersbourg
comme Vladimir Poutine pendant la
période soviétique il était en prison
pour des délits de droit commun et en
1990 au moment de l'effondrement de
l'empire soviétique et bien il est sorti
de détention a commencé par monter une
affaire de vente de hot-dog qui a marché
puis la montée un restaurant de luxe ou
se pressaient les oligarques russes et
en 2000 Vladimir Poutine arrive au
pouvoir en Russie et lui offre des
contrats des contrats à son groupe de
restauration pour servir le Kremlin et
l'armée russe il gagne beaucoup d'argent
et à ce moment on le surnomme le
cuisinier de Vladimir Poutine et à
partir de ce moment là et bien il y
avait gagné Prigogine a ouvert des
centaines de sociétés dans divers
domaines les médias l'extraction de
minerai le conseil politique puis
également des sociétés écran pour
pouvoir commercer avec l'Occident et
également une entreprise pour inonder
internet de fausses informations sur sa
personnalité alors en lisant la presse
régionale ce matin et bien je suis tombé
sur un article du Progrès de Lyon à
propos d'un Français qui connaît bien il
y avait gagné Prigogine un jurassien
Florian Florian bourgeois qui a
travaillé pour lui il était directeur
commercial de son groupe de restauration
dans les années 2000 et donc il décrit
un peu sa personnalité je le cite en
c'était un personnage tyrannique
intransigeant il avait cette violence
cette violente cette violence pardon
sous-jacente et Florian bourgeois le dit
il a été viré deux fois parié de gagner
Prigogine avant d'être réembauché deux
fois car ce personnage n'aimait pas
de lui résiste et puis il parle aussi de
sa relation à l'époque avec Vladimir
Poutine il a toujours entendu il y a de
gagner Prigogine être très élogieux
vis-à-vis du président de la Russie un
mot sur Wagner puisque évidemment quand
on pense que quand on pense frigorne on
pense vague et oui alors avec l'argent
de toute ses affaires en 2014 et prix et
goji n'a fondé fondé ce groupe
paramilitaire privé composé d'abord de
vétérans de l'armée russe des services
spéciaux mais aussi d'anciens
prisonniers recrutés en échange
d'amnistie pendant des années cette
ministre Wagner composée de plusieurs
milliers d'hommes à officier comme
l'armée secrète de Vladimir Poutine elle
n'était reconnue par personne même pas
parigojin lui-même et depuis 2015
effectivement elle est intervenue dans
plusieurs pays la Syrie la Libye de
nombreux pays africains et évidemment en
Ukraine et c'est vraiment en 2022 au
moment de l'invasion de l'Ukraine que
Prigogine a reconnu être à la tête du
groupe Wagner ces hommes ont notamment
mené le siège de darkmouth et il y avait
gagné prigogène à ce moment de critiquer
ouvertement sur les réseaux sociaux la
stratégie de l'état-major russe il est
ce qu'on pouvait s'attendre à ce qui
s'est passé ce weekend non je
personnellement enfin on pouvait
s'attendre moi personnellement
il y a toujours des gens qui vont se
pousser du col et qui vous dire que ils
avaient imaginé que pédagogie puisse
faire ça c'est quand même une surprise
énorme ce qui s'est produit dans la
journée et dans la soirée de vendredi
personne ne pouvait imaginer
enfin vous pouvez imaginer que ça puisse
se passer comme ça et le dénouement
aussi d'ailleurs le dénouement est assez
surprenant il faut le dire et ce qui est
intéressant c'est de savoir que va faire
Prigogine chez le cachenko maintenant
Biélorussie est-ce qu'il va
arriver en appui justement de Moscou
pour attaquer le l'ouest de la de
l'Ukraine depuis comme d'ailleurs
c'était ça avait été fait au tout début
vous souder quand il s'agissait de
prendre Kiev en quelques jours
quels rapport avec le cachenko quelles
sont ses rapports désormais avec Poutine
comment ces hommes dont on dit
aujourd'hui qui sont 25000 c'est lui qui
le dit mais moi j'ai encore en mémoire
il y a quelques jours où il disait j'ai
perdu 30 000 hommes dans dans l'affaire
dans dans cette guerre donc on sait pas
du tout combien il y a de précisément
d'individus dans ce dans cette milice
tout ça ce sont des questions qui sont
pendantes on ne sait rien de tout ça en
revanche ce qu'on sait ce qui me paraît
tout à fait
flagrant c'est ce que Christian a bien
souligné et décortiquer c'est à dire
qu'il y a une grande faiblesse de
Poutine
qui a été révélé à cette à cette
occasion Poutine dont on n'imaginait pas
non plus qui puisse justement et bien
s'accommoder d'un homme comme comme
prigogite dont on pensait que privilégie
était l'obliger on pensait que
privilégier était obligé de Poutine et
on
on s'aperçoit finalement que la
complicité entre les deux hommes c'est
pas tout à fait celle qu'on imaginait
sur cette faiblesse de Poutine mais
Christian machin sur ce que disait Yves
est-ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui ce que
peut peser du coup prégogyne ce qui peut
faire en Biélorussie et oui il est alors
on oublie l'éventail de toutes les
activités de pied gauche on pense à
Wagner qui n'est qu'une branche de ses
activités il a ça a été dit encore
toutes ces activités de restauration de
business il a une énorme activité de
reconversion de toutes les ressources
qu'il a
volé en Afrique et au Moyen-Orient et
c'est encore très actif il y a des
réseaux qui alimentent le système en
l'occurrence le système Poutine ce qui
explique pourquoi Poutine ne lui a pas
couper la tête d'un coup de hache si je
puis dire parce que tout simplement il
ne le peut pas il y a encore des réseaux
des canaux qui permettent à Pigot à prix
gaugine d'avoir des complicités parmi
les olig et de contribuer au système
politique
et ce qui est frappant c'est que un
homme de force présenté comme tel comme
lanière Poutine négocie vous rendez
compte de l'humiliation pour le grand
Sartre de réussite négocie avec un
factieux comme Prigogine pour qu'il
puisse s'évader vers une république
périphérique complètement pourri celle
de Lukachenko
c'est un pour moi un aveu de faiblesse
absolument accablant pour Vladimir
Poutine
c'est une menace pour Vladimir Poutine
non ce n'est pas une menace mais c'est
le cœur du système voilà c'est ça qu'il
faut comprendre
il y a comme des poupées russes les
matériauxchka qui s'emboîtent l'une dans
l'autre il y a des mafia
qui s'imbriquent les unes dans l'autre
et à l'intérieur de ce système prégogène
est incrusté donc vous ne pouvez pas
l'arracher comme ça sans arracher toute
une série de coffrages tout autour qui
vont faire des dégâts donc il faut
isoler pigogine donc d'où l'idée de le
mettre en Biélorussie si l'obtempère
parce que j'attends de voir j'attends de
voir deuxièmement il y a encore un doute
car nous ne connaissons pas quel
garantie pégriger une qui connaît le
terme exact de l'accord personne à ce
jour mais pris goji n'a certainement
obtenu d'autres garanties dont on a fait
on ne fait pas état ce matin mais il y a
sûrement des choses de quoi s'agit-il je
ne sais pas mais il faut attendre pour
en savoir plus toujours est-il que en
faisant ressortir shoegoût de sa boîte
ce matin et puis probablement dans les
jours qui viennent Vladimir Poutine
tranche clairement en faveur de l'État
mais le mal est fait il a été démontré
que l'État russe n'a plus le monopole de
la violence légale Wagner
passager quelque part et sans
soulèvement populaire sans et moins
particulier à l'intérieur du peuple
russe donc c'est encore à l'intérieur du
clan dirigeant que les contes se règle
et par dessus la tête du peuple qui
franchement n'a absolument pas réagi
dans cette affaire-là
ce qui paraît probable c'est que
Prigogine et le détenteur de beaucoup de
secrets et notamment les secrets de la
fortune de le Poutine de la fortune et
probablement d'autres choses et que
c'est comme ça qu'il tient d'ailleurs
d'une certaine façon Poutine et que
Poutine ne pouvait pas lui couper la
tête
sans que ça ait des conséquences
terribles sur lui-même probablement un
des éléments que que je voulais préciser
mais j'ai parlé trop vite c'est que à ce
jour prigogi même s'il perdait le
contrôle de Wagner puisque Wagner selon
les ordres de Poutine doit réintégrer
l'armée régulière sous les ordres des
officiers de la irrégulière autrement
dit c'est la fin de Wagner comme force
autonome
néanmoins privés garde son activité
principale qui est son usine à troll
c'est là le régime a encore besoin ça
explique beaucoup de choses pourquoi
Poutine négocie avec un factieux alors
qu'il devrait l'écraser comme une mouche
il négocie parce que brigogine a encore
et la force encore la main sur la force
d'intoxication et de désinformation la
plus importante du régime russe à savoir
l'usine à troll que Monsieur Prigogine
entretient
dans ces magnifiques locaux qu'il a
inauguré l'an dernier
à ça pardon à Saint-Pétersbourg à grand
frais de publicité donc si vous voulez
privigogine n'a pas disparu du tout du
paysage
est-ce que vous le dites Vladimir
Poutine serai de ces dernières heures
quelles conséquences du coup sur la
guerre en Ukraine et sur la
contre-offensive ukrainienne en cours il
faut voir ce que ça effectivement parce
que c'est aussi une des une des choses
qu'il faut souligner c'est que la guerre
d'Ukraine elle a été conduite et menée
par Prigogine une partie dans tous les
cas du du Front a été tenu par lui
baroute c'est dont on a d'en parler ça a
été l'oeuvre de Prigogine et qui a
finalement réussi à faire tomber cette
ville au profit des Russes ou en partie
en tous les cas et donc c'est aussi une
des pièces essentielles probablement de
de de
l'offensive de Vladimir Poutine voulu
par Vladimir Poutine c'est que on a vu
une armée régulière qui paraissait un
peu une armée de Bourbaki complètement
mal organisé mal commandé avec une
chaîne de commandement
défaillante et à côté de ça et bien la
milice de
d'origine qui elle était tenue qui a
réussi donc à obtenir un une victoire
sur le sol ukrainien et à qui d'ailleurs
Poutine a rendu hommage parce qu'il a
cité à la prise de barmut vous soudez il
y a ce message de Poutine et Poutine
remercie d'une certaine façon Laurent
hommage à la milice Wagner donc c'est ça
qui est tout à fait
incroyable et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
que Poutine a besoin de la mer il peut
pas s'en passer s'il veut continuer
cette guerre en tous les cas pour le
moment en Ukraine du coup ça affaiblit
la Russie face à la contre-offensive
ukrainienne ce qui s'est passé cette
dernière heure Christian macaron
état de le mesurer parce qu'on manque
d'informations mais probablement que les
Ukrainiens n'ont plus en face non plus
que constater
assez vite un certain désordre face à
eux d'ailleurs il y a beaucoup
d'informations et parce mais tout de
même qui convergent qui font état d'une
avancée assez nette dans les trois
derniers jours des
Ukrainiens alors il faut pas extrapoler
la façon dont les rues sont organisées
la défense est impressionnante ils ont
parfois des lignées de défense d'une
épaisseur de 30 km avec les fameuses
dents de dragons antichard en béton etc
donc ça va être toujours très difficile
comme combat et très meurtrier pour les
Ukrainiens mais néanmoins
voir la Russie touchée à la tête au
sommet de cette manière là c'est très
réalisateur pour la Russie et ça ne peut
qu'encourager les
Ukrainiens pensaient à l'effet moral à
l'intérieur des armées de l'armée russe
qui peut entendre par bouche à oreille
toujours déformé d'ailleurs des rumeurs
de cou d'État ou de choses de ce type là
ce n'était pas le cas mais c'est très
mauvais pour le moral d'une armée qui
justement est en position de défensive
face à la contrefacie des
Ukrainiens et enfin l'effet étranger est
accablant il n'y a eu pour soutenir
Poutine que le turcardoane le chinois
est resté aux abonnés absents on n'a pas
entendu la Chine s'exprimer pendant
toute la journée
Poutine a perdu le lustre éventuel qui
pouvait avoir encore par rapport à ses
copains dictateur autoritaire donc même
parmi ce cercle si peu fréquentable il
n'est plus le King qu'il était jusque là
et on suivra bien sûr ces prochaines
heures et ce qui va se passer et les
conséquences évidemment de c'est passé
ce week-end sur la contre-offensive
ukrainienne d'abord on regarde ce
qu'elle a une de nos quotidiens
régionaux avec Alex
[Musique]
et Alex on revient à Marseille
puisqu'elle a une de la presse régionale
ce matin la presse de Marseille en tout
cas cette visite d'Emmanuel Macron et
oui un long déplacement pour lancer
l'acte 2 du plan de président de la
République Marseille en grand avec des
dossiers chauds sur la santé l'école
l'insécurité dans les quartiers il sera
attendu au tournant et si le journal La
Marseillaise Emmanuel Macron qui livre
une grande interview dans le journal La
Provence avec des annonce sur la lutte
contre le trafic de drogue il annonce
une compagnie de CRS supplémentaire à
l'automne des modules de prévention dans
les lycées pour justement évoquer les
risques liés au trafic de drogue et puis
les amendes forfaitaire pour
consommation de drogue pourront être
payés immédiatement soit en carte soit
en liquide cela permet de régler
davantage d'amende car il y a trop peu
d'amendes pour consommation de drogues
qui sont réglées estimer Emmanuel Macron
notamment à Marseille
pour les services d'urgence cet été mais
oui même si le discours du ministre de
la santé est assez optimiste sur l'état
de nos urgences cet été et bien les
professionnels eux estiment que la
situation sera pire que l'an dernier
selon syndicat sémurgence de France et
bien il manque toujours de plus en plus
de lit faute de soignants elle est
signée de souffrance et de mauvais état
de santé des patients sont inquiétants
et la loi risque qui a plafonné le
recours aux intérimaires a mis à genoux
certains établissements en anesthésiste
en imagerie en gynécologue et en
soignant urgentiste donc le syndicat a
créé une hausse de la mortalité à cet
été de nouvelles méthodes pédagogiques
face aux failles de notre système
éducatif c'est dans Midi en Occitanie il
y a apparemment des méthodes qui
marchent pour lutter contre le
décrochage scolaire dans les collèges de
Vergeze et de Fabrègues et de Fabrègues
deux professeurs d'anglais de
mathématiques ont expérimenté le concept
de classe de flexible il s'agit
d'organiser et bien dans la salle de
classe différents ateliers différents
espaces sur un même sujet
d'apprentissage et les élèves peuvent
évoluer sur ces espaces voilà plus de
flexibilité et apparemment c'est
efficace fini par du sport un Breton
comme vous qui fait la Une effectivement
en breton qui devient champion de France
de cyclisme le Brestois Valentin madois
ça a remporté hier le championnat de
France à cassé le nord et il va donc
pouvoir arborer son beau maillot très
color à chaque étape du Tour de France
et on finit en parlant d'une autre
sportive mais cette fois dans un sport
automobile assez original elle s'appelle
Denise à la 72 ans et elle est pilotes
de caisse à savon ce sont les véhicules
sans moteur qui se déplacent simplement
avec la pesanteur donc c'est souvent des
courses de descente et de virage et
depuis 20 ans et bien elle participe à
toutes les courses de caisse à savon en
Alsace et dans les Vosges et on découvre
les caisses à savon
la une
pièce
matin dans Le Figaro
qui sont consacrés c'est bien normal à
l'Ukraine et à la Russie et c'est à dire
merci
beaucoup de nous avoir suivis pour voir
revoir cette émission c'est sur public
sénat.fr à 18h sans public à 19h30 on
vous retrouve vive monsieur Tanguy qui
est donc l'une des figures du
rassemblement national et ce sera à
suivre sur notre antenne on se retrouve
demain très bonne journée
[Musique]